こんにちはドカーン
あんまり oo を済まない皆さんここに大量のモザイクがかかっているがあとで話し
ます今は気にしないでください皆さんは髪の毛を顔出すときどのように彼はたしますか
もちろん自然乾燥ナチュラルドライというものがあるんですけども神時が有る保存の一
つ買ってるでしょ
ドライヤーかと思いますこちらにも素敵な際あるんですけどもうドライヤーを使うこと
によって
自然乾燥夕焼はるかに早く時間を短縮し神強化できる素晴らしいものがありますで子が
この私のこの髪の毛目のなるさあでも顔八坂は河川には約56分かかってしまうこの
ためだけの泣かせで私で後6分かかってしまうということは女性どうか僕より髪の毛
ながらキモロン毛様とことがもっと髪の毛長い人だったらめちゃくちゃ時間かかって
しまうんじゃないからパ
釣りだったら1日と2時間くらい髪の毛を乾かすのに使えそう
付けるのもったいないんですよドライヤーだきっぷを使っていると
っていうことで今回村井ドライヤーを大量に準備しました
もうお気づきだろうドライヤー一つで乾かせる力
限られてますよね結局ドライ&やっていることってシンプルなんですよ熱風を髪の毛で
吹きかけるこれだけのことで
数えて熱意を増やしすぎても良くないと思うんですよ髪の毛が痛むのでなのでメッツの
温度を増やさず雨量
熱風時代の数を増やせるに大量のドライヤーを準備しました
ああああああああ
あーこれで髪の毛がビザビ茶の状態ではいりょうドライヤーで一気に熱風本指に
吹きかけると難聴は何度ですね
私の仮説が正しければずるく
3秒にギアで私の旅だったら壊れてしまうそんな気がしてならんのですよ
というわけで今回の実験はこの大量のドライヤーを使い3秒で髪の毛が渇く最強の橋を
作ると思う
でバイクを買うよ
てなかなかいい力がありますね作戦としては
永長香典ドライ合わせとしまくって全部を本にした状態で一気に高精度挿せば全部
設置が入りますそうしなければびっくりこそのスイッチは on にしなきゃいけない
のがめんどくさいのでコンセントの方々とを断ちますでは
前そしてもう一重になってくるのはドライ&ファッショ
もう髪の毛が濡れ
た状態で側に入ってして覚えて分いって乾かせばいいじゃないと思うんで
こういう場所柄ツイードライダースとしていければいいじゃんいいなと思いますね
こんなイメージですねこんなイメージ本当に水
はぁ
tee
oo
女の性がありませんヤバ
ているわけだん
人がここに立つので若干ドライヤーの
この口を僕の方に向くようにちょっとずつ考慮生て今全部交互に行きます転載
[音楽]
痛い怖い
ちゃん眠コアいます
寝る方も惚れだけあれば絶対一緒に反撃乾かせますからね
はいというわけで釣らせしましたこれが一瞬でしゃべるの髪の毛を乾かす最強の
マシーン
博奕ファイルドライヤーです
僕は結構身長高いでここらへん店になるんですけどもご覧くださいすべてのドライヤー
の口が私の方を向いておりますここでこう一斉に風を浴びて髪の毛を一緒で顔かつて
作戦でございますそれだけだぞ
スプラッシュこれで準備完了際こんなにピジョンいうで髪の毛も今度は数使えば一瞬で
かわけで背負ってばいきます
yeah
あっ
あっはぁ
ここまで読んでいたぞ昔も同じようなことで大量の電力を使うすると家のブレーカーが
落ちるという現象が起きたのでまあ
ここまで読んでいました勝負はここからですなぜ私がにを2つかれているかわかるか
越冬
1人堂々とためですねしていた車種電力をに過疎から供給できるか今なぜブレーカーが
落ちたというとこの家の電力にたいきれずブレーカーが落ちてしまったのでこのせ
レザードライヤーの電力にこの映画たいきれなかったってことなんで女性どのぐらいの
電力の半分おかじまみゅーずめんとパークの全力から供給します
そうするとこの家にかかる電力は半分に抑えられるのでブレーカーが落ちない可能性が
あるんですよと言うけど大量の延長コーとさらに用意したので
kazumi アミューズメントパークから電力をとってくるでは以下わぁ
じゃあここから全力ございます
あった
[音楽]
ん
というわけでお待たせしましたちょっともう家水カロ数
水わけでお待たせいたしました2つの良いが電力を供給し
ブレーカー農地を最大まで気がした採集方法です
これでこんなメジャーな日目も一瞬で書きます出会いかこっちがはじめニュースネット
ワーカーの電力
くっちがこの部屋の天力ってばまいります
ツリー2まあ
ああああああ
[音楽]
加瀬 hanano
me
teame
car
uh